[Music]
i want pure colors melting clouds
accurately drawn details a sunburst
above a receding road with the light
reflected in furrows and ruts after rain
and no girls this was vladimir nabakov's
wish regarding the cover art for his
most famous and most controversial novel
the difficulty of publishing a book like
lolita not to mention the difficulty of
how to market and sell the novel has
been consistent since its first
publishing in 1955 the original
publishers olympia press discarded the
problem entirely by displaying nothing
pictorial at all
other editions of the novel took a
similar approach
however by 1962 matters changed as pop
culture started to consume and interpret
the novel
in new ways
stanley kubrick's movie of lolita marks
a clear change in the attitude of book
publishers
[Music]
how did they ever make a movie of lolita
turns out they
didn't though i don't want to give a
complete summary of either book or movie
1955's lolita is a disturbing and
deceptively written novel about a man
humbert humbert preying upon and
sexually abusing a 12 year old child
the movie on the other hand is played as
a dark comedy
bringing up lolita's age 216 and
the abuse is only vaguely implied this
disconnect between movie lolita and book
lolita is what fuels
popular consciousness and continues to
inform book marketing from 1962 forward
the promotional image of sue lyon and
the heart-shaped sunglasses taken by
photographer ben stern
is easily the most significant culprit
once this image became associated with
lolita it really didn't matter that it
was a terribly inaccurate portrait
it became the image of lolita and it was
ubiquitous
book publishing took a cue from the
movie after the success of the film
lolita had become a sex symbol at the
heart of all this
seems to be the desire to make the
sexual aspect of the novel more
palatable it's ironic that in attempting
to make aspects of the novel more
palatable film and book marketers were
overtly sexualizing
a child character designer peter
mendelson argues that in attempting to
sell a book
designers must not always but sometimes
pander to a public that on occasion
lacks the interpretive subtlety to parse
literary subtext
that is to say if the general reading
public expects a school
girl or a school girl uniform on a
lolita jacket
then book buyers and booksellers will
also be expecting a school girl or
school girl uniform on a lolita jacket
and one can then reasonably assume that
marketing departments and publishing
houses will want them as well
in the end going backward upriver
towards its source even editors begin to
take their cues from misinformed readers
at large
dieter e zimmer's online gallery
covering lolita where i found most of
these book covers
offers a fascinating view of lolita's
publishing history ending with
contemporary publications
still today designers must contend with
the question of how to depict a
character who was seen entirely through
the eyes of their abuser
in lolita the story of a cover girl
edited by john bertram and yuri leving
this issue is posed to a number of
artists
unrestrained by commercial demands the
designs confront the subject in a number
of ways
usually indirectly some artists focus on
objects relating to lolita
some focus on the language of the novel
however most never attempt to portray
the character in a direct way
for example this design plays with the
idea that lolita is
impossible to portray on a book cover
even the word is blurry and distant the
design that really stands out to me
however
is this
for years lolita has had her identity
stolen and transformed she has been the
lurid object on a book cover as seen
through the eyes of her abuser but in
this design what appears to be humbert
humber
displayed in his monstrous reality is
finally the subject
the name and persona of lolita is just a
manifestation of his sickness and we
finally see the true subject of the book
for whoever is responsible for marketing
and selling the novel publishing lolita
will always pose a problem
after all it's an incredibly nuanced
incredibly deceptive narrative and
popular culture has not treated lolita
the character
with much nuance in some ways it's
almost a curse that such a novel should
become so famous
and to become subject to such a
[Music]
misinterpretation